Hey, David, can someone who didn't win the
Iowa caucus still win the nomination?
Absolutely.
I've said from the start, especially because
of the compression of you've got Iowa was
Monday, February 3rd, we've then gotten New
Hampshire.
We then have a Nevada, then we South Carolina,
and then all within a month.
Then it's super Tuesday, March 3rd, where
you have a whole bunch of delegates.
The importance of the first couple is mostly
PR.
The PR was a disaster because of the completely
failed way in which the DNC carried out the
caucus, the failure of the app that they developed.
I mean it just an embarrassing, complete and
total mess, which allowed multiple candidates
to essentially claim that they won it.
Let Donald Trump laugh at everybody on Twitter,
which he did very, very successfully.
Quite frankly, it really played into his hands.
But the 41 delegates from Iowa are not make
or break in any way other than, uh, justifying
from a PR standpoint that you are viable,
right?
Getting some delegates in Iowa gets you past
zero and that's what matters.
But you know, Iowa is only 41 delegates.
Um, New Hampshire is 24 delegates, even smaller
than Nevada is 36 delegates, also smaller
than Iowa, but not by much.
The largest of the first four primaries is
South Carolina where 54 delegates are awarded.
But remember with proportional allocation,
if you get 25% of the vote and someone else
gets 20% of the vote, you both end up with
almost the same number of delegates.
Now the thing I would be more concerned about
at this point, the primaries are going to
happen and the delegate counts are going to
start to add up and only after super Tuesday
are the pads going to start to mathematically
get harder and harder.
After super Tuesday we will be able to make
calculations like for example, based on all
of the voting so far in order for the third
place person to win, they would have to get,
you know, call it 50% of all remaining delegates
are making the numbers up and then we would
be able to start to say, well, they've only
gotten 12% of the delegates so far.
How likely is it that from here on out they
get half of the remaining delegates and even
though they will stay and we will be able
to start mathematically closing the road so
to speak, the path will begin to close for
a lot of different candidates.
For now.
It's all wide open.
Here's the really important thing.
What I want to see is what the DNC pulse,
okay.
We've been talking about this for a while.
When it comes to superdelegates, when it comes
to the debate requirements at the beginning
of the week, I told you the DNC is doing the
thing we thought they might do for a long
time, which is they're changing the debate
qualification requirements in a way that would
make one really important change.
It would allow Michael Bloomberg to participate
in the debates even without accepting individual
donors.
By removing that as a requirement.
There have started to be all sorts of rumblings
about, you know, is John Kerry going to swoop
in as Joe Biden fails?
I don't think that's going to happen, but
it's a conversation that was floating around.
Will the DNC put all of its weight behind
a different establishment candidate?
We saw that the establishment candidates by,
by voting, um, uh, entrance polls in the Iowa
caucuses, um, are Biden boot edge edge and
Klobuchar will the DNC switch.
But most importantly, there are now a number
of reports including one we did on the Tuesday
bonus show saying that the NC executives are
talking about can we put super delegates back
in the first round of voting.
And to understand the importance of that,
you have to understand what happened back
in 2016 back in 2016 superdelegates, which
are party insiders and other sort of higher
ups designated people in the D in the democratic
party.
They got to vote in addition to the delegates
that were won in primaries at the democratic
national convention.
So as Bernie and Hillary were fighting it
out and they were close and they were one
of the, we knew all along that because all
of these super delegates were pledged to Hillary
Clinton, that once you get to that first vote
at the convention, no matter what happens
in the primaries, even if it's tight, Hillary
gets the nomination because of the super delegates,
incredibly unfair and undemocratic.
So since 2016 the democratic party agreed
not to allow super delegates to vote in the
first round at the DNC.
So the idea is the delegates vote in the first
round at the democratic convention based on
state results.
If no one wins on the first round, then they
do a second round where super delegates get
to vote.
That was what we knew up until Monday, starting
Tuesday after the Iowa fiasco, DNC executives
have started to have a conversation about
could we maybe go back on that?
Could we maybe get the super delegates back
into voting in the first round?
They seem to recognize that it would enrage
millions of people and rightly so because
it's completely anti-democratic.
But there is a conversation that is taking
place and I would be looking at that more
than who has the mathematical path right now
because Iowa, New Hampshire, it's going to
be wide open going into super Tuesday.
Um, uh, that's for sure.
Let's see what the DNC plans to do.